we're impatiently waiting for the third
season of stranger things to be released
and were not the only ones the newest
season is set to come out on Netflix in
July of 2019 and fans aren't wasting any
time in coming up with wild theories
kind of hawk what's ten o'clock
watch until the end to find out what
back to the future and stranger things
have in common all about the poster fans
are bustling with happiness at the
confirmation of stranger things third
season and with good reason - it's been
over a year since the second season was
released leaving plenty of time for fans
to speculate on what's to come instead
of dismissing their wildest theories the
duffer brothers are choosing to add fuel
to the fire by releasing some pretty
confusing evidence for the time being we
have more than enough to crack the code
but only time will tell if we've managed
to come up with some worthy evidence to
rile us up a short an eerie video was
posted online and it displayed every
single episode the stranger things cast
has been working on with eight
frightening titles to sift through it's
a wonder that anyone's managed to get
some sleep on top of that Netflix also
released a short teaser as well as a
promotional image which has caused fans
to look for clues in the most unlikely
of places the series is set to air on
America's Independence Day which could
very well be the reason behind the
fireworks we see in the promotional
image and curiously enough the words one
summer can change everything are
displayed at the top of the poster this
sentence leads us to believe that the
third season will take place in the
summertime instead of focusing on the
kids during their school year 11 Mike
will Lucas Max and Dustin can easily be
spotted out however only 11 and Will's
eyes are turned towards the viewer this
booster is the cause for minion answered
questions and it's only going to get
worse from here Freegal right now the
episode titles
although most series wait until their
release date to display the seasons
episodes the Duggar brothers aren't
wasting any time in fact they've chosen
to give us some tiny spoilers to tie us
over why didn't you tell us before
I wasn't sure or not so let's take a
look at what we've been given first on
the list is the episode Susie do you
copy
which will be the first episode of the
season
seems to be a strange title especially
since the only character named Susan is
none other than Max's mom second on the
list is the episode the Mallrats
which hints towards our favorite teen
spending a lot of time at the Hawkins
mall
although hanging out at the mall is a
normal thing for teens to do there's
nothing normal about the star Court mall
next up is the case of the missing
lifeguard which makes us turn a curious
eye towards water in general following
these episodes are the ones titled the
sauna test the source the birthday the
bite in the Battle of star Court from
what we gather this season will begin
and end at the star Court mall where a
new threat is said to be lurking
underneath the ground stae goodbye -
love triangles it's no secret that Mike
and xi have had a shaky start which is
why fans are eager to see the couple
come to life before their eyes sadly
there's nothing like a love triangle to
keep fuse at an all-time high
knowing those fans are taking to Reddit
to express how much they don't want Mike
and Elevens relationship to falter but
since Mike and Elevens relationship is
one of the biggest selling points for
children their age a love triangle has
been ruled for good in fact the show's
executive producer Shawn Levy recently
told CNN entertainment that the third
season of stranger things would showcase
Mike and Elevens relationship as well as
Max and Lucas's all in all it looks like
love triangles will be ruled out for
good you won't lose me
you promise so despite being used to the
Nancy Steve Jonathan merry-go-round this
too should come to an end
on top of that Joyce is freshly single
after tragically losing Bob so this
leaves room for hopper to step in now
that we've got that out of the way let's
find out what the wild theories are that
have been brewing on the Internet theory
one the spider the mind flayer goes by
many names which can make it hard to
pinpoint whereas some of us know him as
the shadow monster others have called
him the spider for obvious reasons
although season two of stranger things
had us believing that the upside down
was closed once and for all
hints of the spiders arms can be seen
poking around the edges of the season
three poster in this poster we see a
handful of clues that are hard to
decipher with just one look but upon
deeper examination it looks like
something is coming for the coolest gang
in town in this poster we see is scared
looking 11 looking at what appears to be
the head of a spider II foe funny enough
will is the only other character who is
looking the monsters way
could this be hinting at the fact that
only will and 11 have the power to see
their newest enemy if so this poses a
huge threat for the other members of the
gang some fans speculate that the entire
poster is seen through a monsters point
of view which makes more than a little
sense while Lukas Max and Dustin are in
the background enjoying the fireworks
will and 11 are seeing something else
entirely in this poster we see Mike
staring at 11 as she turns to take a
look at what's behind her the first
episode that's said to air is Susie do
you copy
which could hint towards a police
officer going missing during a Hawkins
festivity could it be that there's a new
monster in town one that can only be
seen by people who have ties to the
upside-down
if so Hawkins is in more danger than
ever okay theory - the rats have eyes is
there anything more disgusting than rats
we don't think so but that didn't stop
producers from placing rats all over
their new stranger things poster and
since nothing is a coincidence fans
believe that rats will pose a threat to
humans and animals alike it's no secret
that rats carry diseases and hide in
towers and underground tunnels which
could make them easy prey for any
upside-down creatures lurking below
the presence of rats makes us think
about laboratories and testing
facilities after all Hopkins knows a
little too much about these kinds of
organizations I don't know there are two
theories surrounding rats that are worth
exploring the first one being that an
upside down creature will be infecting
rats with its DNA with hopes of
contaminating anyone who comes in
contact with them this could shed some
light on the episode titled the bite
which could very well follow a Hawkins
residents transformation after they've
been bitten by a rat another theory
surrounding these critters are lab rats
as a whole as many of you know eleven
and a handful of other children were
used as lab rats during their youth and
while the experiments they suffered gave
them powers it also caused them pain and
loss some fans believe that the rats are
being used as a metaphor for these
children and that many of Elevens
brothers and sisters will be making an
appearance come season three and if this
is true it could very well mean that
eleventh Papa is coming back to Hawkins
for his prized possession after all it
was confirmed that he was still alive at
the end of season two theory three
fireworks we're so used to seeing our
favorite game down in the dumps that
seeing them happy makes us feel uneasy
after all they tend to have a lot on
their plate so despite their being a
cause for celebration it seems as though
these friends aren't out of the woods
just yet
the stranger thinks poster might have
fireworks in the background but there
seems to be a bigger threat at hand on
top of that the stranger thinks teaser
clearly showcases a new year's
celebration gone wrong there's a fan
theory brewing that just might shock you
and it goes a little something like this
whatever monster is terrorizing Hawkins
enjoys crowds and might be feeding off
their energy to reopen the upside-down
eleven made it clear that closing the
upside down took a lot of energy which
is why she nearly died from exhaustion
so could it be that an invisible monster
with a huge and spidery shadow is
seeking out crowds to undo her actions
this could explain why the monster made
an appearance during Independence Day as
well as New Year's Day and it could also
shine some light on the episode titled
the birthday although we have little to
no detail about the sixth episode of the
season we can only imagine that
festivities will be cut short for a good
reason it's possible that this spooky
monster is blind as well and that he
uses rats as a means to eavesdrop on the
outside world should this be the case it
would make sense that he's attracted a
larger crowd since loud music and voices
can be heard from a distance but for now
this is all purely theoretical theory
for blue and yellow everything that
comes attached to stranger things has a
creepy vibe to it which is why we're not
surprised that one of its teasers gave
us the heebie-jeebies in this clip we
see what appears to be a live broadcast
of New York's Times Square during the
new year's countdown throughout this
video bouts of green coding flash across
the screen with some questionable words
and sentences attached to it at some
point we even hear what appears to be
Mike shouting eleventh name dedicated
stranger things fans use Morse code to
decipher one of the images which led
them to discover the phrase when blue
and yellow meet in the West this
puzzling sentence has us grasping for
answers in all the wrong places but fans
came to the conclusion that Mike and 11
are tied to these colors in fact 11 is
seen wearing blue in the poster whereas
Mike can be found wearing yellow so what
does this mean for now we're inclined to
believe that the crew will be taking a
road trip to the coast where they can
investigate a missing persons case and
since the third episode of the season is
titled the case of the missing lifeguard
we can only imagine that this episode
will touch down on our speculations by
now we all know that the upside-down
isn't a fan of fire but we haven't the
slightest clue how it will fare in the
open waters could it be that an
upside-down creature has found its way
into a body of water where it's
infecting everyone who drinks or swims
in it for now we're inclined to believe
that blue might signify water and yellow
the Sun and since the Sun sets in the
west
perhaps this clue points towards the
horizon theory 5 the countdown the
Deborah brothers were inspired by old
80's movies when creating the stranger
themed series so it's not surprising
that they'll be drawing inspiration from
some of the decades biggest hits
executive producer Shawn Levy empty
towards the 3rd season taking a page
from the Back to the Future film which
first aired in the summer of 1985 and
coincidence or not the third season of
stranger things also takes place during
the very same summer many fans are
inclined to believe that stranger things
will focus on time travel this time
around this could explain why the
seasons teaser took place on New Year's
Eve while the poster proudly showcased
the fourth of July could it be that the
stranger things gained has to travel
through time to stop the mind flare from
settling down on earth if so we can't
wait to see what the timeline has in
store for us
the final episode of the third season is
titled the Battle of Star Court which
makes us believe that the Hawkins mall
will be the focal point of that
time-traveling operation and what better
way to turn back the hands of time then
4:11 to use the malls huge water
fountain as ammo so there you have it
the top 5 most mind-blowing stranger
things theories we have yet to encounter
although theories are bound to change as
more information is released the first
round of theories seems pretty darn
convincing so which theory seems most
likely from your point of view let us
know in the comments below
and that's a wrap if you love stranger
things as much as we do don't forget to
hit that subscribe button for our newest
videos to come your way thanks for
watching and see you next time on the
scenes
[Music]